so yesterday we played the clip of joe
biden unveiling his plan to help
struggling business owners
in the wake of the lockdowns that have
crippled them uh in a sign of things to
come
biden says that his administration's
priority will be black latino native
american and women business owners in
other words
white males are out of luck so let's
play that again in case you missed it
here it is
our focus will be on small businesses on
main street
that aren't wealthy and well connected
that are facing real economic hardships
through no
fault of their own our priority will be
black latino asian and native
american-owned small businesses
women-owned businesses
and finally having equal access to
resources needed to reopen and rebuild
now as always with these things if you
want to understand just how outrageously
racist it is just play it back in your
mind but insert
white male instead of black or latino
imagine if joe biden had said
our priority will be white males and
white women
there would be a volcanic eruption of
outrage in response to such a statement
nearly every person in the country
would condemn it as the height of racism
so
is it different if you fill in the blank
with a different race no of course not
the reaction is different what people
say about it is different but
it's not actually different um yeah
imagine also actually being a white male
business owner some of you may not have
to imagine this because you are
you're on the brink of bankruptcy in
desperate need of some help
due to the government's own actions and
now imagine that you you don't get the
help you need
because of your race and gender are you
supposed to be okay with that are you
supposed to
look down at your white skin and say
well all right i guess i
do deserve to lose my livelihood at
least the latinos are getting help
i suppose that's how biden expects them
to react or perhaps not biden it's not
clear that biden expects anything
it's not clear that he knows what
centuries in or planet he's on but the
radicals calling the shots
for him do expect it speaking of
radicals tucker carlson had a disturbing
segment last night about kristen
clarke clark has been tapped to lead the
doj
civil rights division this means that
she'll be a very powerful figure in the
administration
and given that she's in charge of
enforcing quote-unquote civil rights
it's important to know how she views the
subject right
well tucker had obtained a letter that
clarke wrote back in 1994
when she was the president of the black
studies association at harvard
clark was looking to educate the public
on the topic of
race science and if race science
sounds like horrible quackery if it
sounds like something you
might learn at medical school in nazi
germany that's because it is
so here's tucker reading the letter
listen please use the following theories
and observations to assist you in your
search for truth regarding the genetic
differences between blacks and whites
end quotes you know it's going to be
interesting and it was quote
one dr richard king reveals that the
core of the human brain
is the locus corulius which is a
structure that is black
because it contains large amounts of
neuromelanin which is essential for its
operation
two black infants sit crawl and walk
sooner than whites three carol barnes
notes that human mental processes are
controlled
by melanin that same chemical which
gives blacks their superior physical and
mental abilities
four some scientists have revealed that
most whites are unable to produce
melanin
because their pineal glands are often
calcified or non-functioning
pineal calcification rates with africans
are 5 to 15 percent
asians 15 to 25 percent and europeans 60
to 80 percent
this is the chemical basis for the
cultural differences between blacks and
whites
and five melanin endows blacks with
greater mental
physical and spiritual abilities
something which cannot be measured based
on eurocentric standards
end quote oh okay
that's science for you now if this
sounds familiar and i heard this and uh
and i
the first thing i thought is i i feel
like i've heard this recently
well if you had the same thought you
might be thinking of this listen
let's go to what it really is then when
we talk about the power of melanated
people
when we talk about who we really are as
guys and understanding that
our melanin is so power and it connects
us in a way
that the reason why they fear black the
reason why they fear is because they
the lack that they have of it so then
when you see
what you know dr uh francis c wellesley
talked about
is that fear in that that that genetic
annihilation efficiency
of when you have a person that has has
the lack of pigment the lack of melon
right
that they know that they will be
annihilated so therefore however they
got the power they
they have the lack of compassion that
melanin comes with compassion melanin
comes with soul that we call it we call
it soul we
soul brothers and sisters that's the
melon in that connection so the people
that don't have it
have are are a lit and i'm gonna say
this carefully
are a little less you said it carefully
they're a little less the entire race of
people a little bit less i always like
in you know we watch clips like that and
uh when someone is babbling incoherently
and somebody else is listening and going
right yeah sure
uh-huh exactly the entire time so anyway
yes the doj civil rights division will
be run by nick cannon
essentially or at least someone as
racist and insane
and stupid as him so a few things to be
said about all this number one it should
go without saying but
the science here is not only wrong but
incoherent
it's not really science at all but
religious dogma a belief that darker
skin
endows one not only with mental and
physical advantages but with greater
spiritual and moral worth
you know white people are a little less
as the scholar nick cannon put it that's
not science at all obviously number two
this sort of race essentialism makes for
really strange bedfellows with
gender non-essentialism which is
increasingly the worldview of everybody
on the left both in the mainstream and
off on the fringes
and the distinction between those two
groups leftist mainstream and leftist
fringe has of course been
almost completely erased at this point a
mainstream leftist
is just a fringe leftist but without the
blue hair in any case
the race essentialist said that says
that races are
biologically distinct that every race
has its own
core essence that's what you heard nick
cannon and kristen clark talking about
and that your race is immutable it's an
unchangeable part of you
but gender non-essentialism on the other
hand says that sex has nothing to do
with biology that there is no core
essence to being a man or a woman
that's why they can't answer my famous
question of what is a woman well a woman
is nothing
although they don't want to say that and
they say you know you can switch between
the two
sexes or you can be neither or you can
be some combination
you know you could be a man on tuesday
and a woman on wednesday there's no
reason why you can't be
in other words they seek to make nearly
everything about you nearly your whole
identity fluid and ambiguous
except your race we are all basically
these
amorphous genderless non-descript
puddles of nothing
but we do have a race at least and god
forbid that an ambiguous
white entity should pretend to be an
ambiguous black entity
never mind that it makes just as much
sense for a white man to say
i feel like a black person and so i am
one as it does for a man to say
i feel like i'm a woman and so i am one
these statements are at least
equal in their incoherence if anything
the former is slightly less incoherent
number three notice how the cycle has
been complete now the leftist
champions for racial equality to include
now even the the woman who will be
heading up the civil rights division
sound exactly like the proponents of jim
crow in the early 20th century
some races have greater spiritual and
moral worth that's exactly what racists
have always said
and that's what people like kristin
clark have pretended that they're
fighting against
but in an outcome that is familiar in
human history they have become
exactly what they said they wanted to
destroy they are so woke
so enlightened so progressive that their
views on race would would have been
totally at home in alabama in the year
1922.
the only difference is which race they
find superior but that is a rather
meaningless
difference really the end goal with all
of this
is to divide and conquer right for all
the talk about unity what we will see in
the coming years is the american
population divided
chopped up segregated into their own
categories
and policies will be applied and laws
enforced differently depending on the
category in which you reside
we are about to see the culmination of
identity politics we're going to see
what it looks like
when the sorts of people who've been
burning our cities for months now have a
whole government at their disposal
and old joe will preside over this half
conscious
barely sentient a useful stooge and
figurehead
an inoffensive and sort of pitiful
vessel for the most extreme radicalism
we have ever seen from our government
that's what's coming up listen hit that
subscribe button
right now do it right now i thank you
for your compliance
it is somewhat appreciated